I love what you two are doing with this
house but what are you gonna do with
five bedrooms you guys are obviously
never having kids
what was that look I did not do a look
you're doing a look right now there's no
look that would apply guys there's so
many kids in foster care
yeah they're having an orientation value
people who taken foster kids are really
special the kind of people who volunteer
when it's not even a holiday we don't
even volunteer on a holiday um first of
all I am a crier I cry watching
commercials I cry and everything but I
didn't know you were a crier
first of all I've heard that you cried
when you read the script and that and
then you had a lot of crying scenes in
this movie was that sort of did it come
very naturally are you is it easy for
you to cry on cue
yeah I like to cry I like to get my kids
going if I keep I'll go out with my
eight year olds if she's not like
feeling that give me a hug in the
morning or a kiss I'll get into the
whole dad's getting emotional on no
she'll come over and give me it is it
real or you get up
no I can I connected I can draw up the
emotions but I tap into it I've got pain
and what is that about this story that
you think is so special I mean it's
obvious watching it but why why do you
think it's so special because it didn't
feel like a film it felt like I was
watching a real story and it is probably
because of that it is inspired by Sean's
life and I've not seen a film like this
really um oh not for a while anyway but
I love the spirit all that I think the
spirit of it is really um unusual and it
gets you on with the laughs but then
sort of takes you down with the
conscious you and they got with the
tears right yeah it's it's real it's
inspiring you know then there are still
lots of children out there that need a
home and to think I'm young boy or girl
not having parents not having a home
having love that's that's pretty pretty
sad so so hopefully people will continue
to be inspired by this and and whatever
it takes to get them to to know for
their homes if they're in a position to
to be able to you know give somebody
else a home and make them a part of
their family films that you guys like to
watch as a family cuz I know you're both
parents if there's anything you know
that you love and which ones they are
those well I'm trying to always try to
get my kids to watch movies like babe
[Music]
but we always go you know
kids pick the movies that they want to
see you know see well my boys is little
but little ones sorry the elder one
likes certain end oh my gosh yeah I've
got big teeth the animated but he calls
it fur demand I still wonder when was on
your list yeah is that true yeah oh yeah
am i watching Wonder Woman with my
daughter who was in a question and has a
owns a horse it was just me and her it
was a great thing ever and you watch
your funny was she really I was like wow
she's awesome better not hurt these
horses a half million children are
currently in foster care the county puts
these on because they can match a lot of
kids in Paris quickly look at the big
kiss everybody's avoiding you know one
side but they're teenagers okay maybes
drugs and they watch people playing
video games on YouTube they're not
equipped for any of that are you this
fYI we can all hear you so because this
is called instant family I wondered if
there's anything that you wish you could
be instantly good at that took time yes
I wish I could be instantly good at
piano and I don't know how to play at
all no no I can't do anything my son Max
who is - he has a little piano and he
sits at that and he really gets that
like you sit and sing at the piano and
he I'm just I'm like a little genius
over there but he's better than I am so
I know you have kids
and what I loved in the movie because I
did this as a kid when Christmas time
comes and you open the presents
the boxes are cooler yet it came in
right have you found that to be the case
with your kids before it's 1,000,000%
forts tunnels everything I mean they
crawl in the box and we can't find one
for a while we have twins yeah they're
two but yeah there's boxes that we can't
we're not allowed to throw out because
they have a fit so we just have these
ugly boxes sitting around our house what
is it about this story obviously this is
Shawn story and it's so special that
it's real it felt very real watching it
felt very personal what is it why do you
think it's so special and what was
special about working on it well I
personally have always been interested
in adoption and I still hope that maybe
it's in my future well I mean I think I
have to give my wife a beat with two
year old twins
so and I'm hoping when she sees to the
movie should be the guy right that's got
a couple of kids but but yeah I think
that it's special because it is based in
truth and it's special because this sort
of coming together is special to make a
conscious decision to incorporate
children into your life have you had any
encounters with real-life families and
rather researching or since making this
movie my very good friends went through
the foster Dopp process in Los Angeles
and and have their daughter now but I
witnessed firsthand the roller coaster
that they went on Lizzy comes with two
younger siblings three kids too much oh
my god
why would you show us that that's wrong
Helia make yourself at home because
you're at home
do you like Cooper so more of a Lakers
fan oh no okay because they like the
Clippers I think the Clippers are
awesome they were smart for trading
Blake Griffin your best player so
there's a scene in the movie where you
guys open your presents but then you
like the box is better does that happen
in real life uh our box is better but
our presents better press it you see I
got this cuz IKEA or slide down is his
box
what was your favorite present ever
I don't know I don't even remember the
present but you remember that what about
you uh probably my PlayStation 4 cool
and what about you what was your
favorite present ever
oh geez oh no no oh go ahead change my
dog beep I mean beep oh no that was the
onset dog oh that's right we thought the
doggy yeah oh I don't know just gift of
life thank you thank you that you didn't
get the gift that she didn't get a cent
oh yeah I'm still waiting for my gift
thank you are you gonna give her sure I
didn't get a tea okay oh yeah I didn't
get a t-shirt I didn't get one like Oh
God why yeah that's true I'm waiting for
my favorite gift uh-oh
so because this is called instant family
I want to know if there's anything you
wish you could be instantly good at
screaming screaming try it it's really
good baby crying thank you
no I can't do that I would want to
you can't do like this right away not
yet singing just a until the fire
department comes okay here's just
another white lady who wants to adopt
charity orphans make you feel good about
your spouse 10 long we might have a
little bit of a knack for this oh I beg
to differ
congratulations on the movie I know
we're not going to see your kids but
your kids are in the room here and it's
I think what makes it so special is that
it's your story and it didn't feel like
a film it felt like I was really
watching a story oh wow so why do you
think it's so special obviously it is
because it's your own story but what do
you think it's why do you think it's
resonating with people so much
I think it's resonating because they can
tell that it is authentic and that it's
a topic that they don't hear about that
often and it's a topic that people
sometimes are afraid of but I think when
they sit down and they see the movie
they realize there's nothing to be
afraid of and that there's a lot of
laughs and there's a lot of joy and a
lot of love there is there there
definitely is so there's a scene in the
movie where it's Christmas and you get
the kids they get the kids you know all
these great presents and they open it
and they're not so excited and they're
more excited about the boxes that
they're gonna turn them into for its
which I used to know is this real did
this really happen this did well I mean
in the sense that every time we get
anything any time there's a box in the
house that becomes the the favorite toy
in the house and and it becomes and I'm
sure a lot of parents have this
experience or after a while you're like
you guys we got to get rid of some of
these boxes do you guys like forts yeah
yes well just kick it we'll just hear
the yes often they like making forces
are the coolest thing obviously you're
so close to this story but sort of
watching it and when you finally put it
down and said I'm finished and watched
it what is it like for you watching your
own story you know it's it's very
emotional because aspects of it are my
own story but aspects of it are also the
stories of other people that I met along
the way
so I know all of the people whether it's
these guys here or or the other families
that I met with along the way or some of
the other people that I met who grew up
and care
and everything that happens to the
characters in the movie is all are all
reflections of those real people so I
get emotional every time I watch it with
an audience because I know where it all
came I get emotional just talking about
it
[Music]
we love you please go away but I'm
pissed we know what I'd like to do
I let me check okay
got my boots daddy what that suck
let's stop of dad hey honey can I help
you with anything
you